(bright orchestral music)
- So a lot of fun today,
this is the first time
back for the volunteers.
The only one for this year,
but we'll be back in the fall
hopefully with three, right?
So stay tuned and watch
for those flyers to come
from the Pathways to Science
people, Maria and crew.
Hey, there's Maria. Thank you, Maria.
(audience applauding)
So the real pleasure today
is to have Dr. Albert Ko
with us here from the Yale
School of Medicine and EPH
He's a chemistry major. It's
almost as good as (indistinct).
Chemistry's a great
subject, not that I'd know.
And MIT, worked at Harvard Med School,
worked at Cornell (indistinct).
He's gonna be able to tell
us more about his career.
And I think the only
thing you need to know is
that our governor Lamont
says Albert's our Dr. Fauci.
(audience laughing)
So, you know, he's really a huge help.
Those of us that had
to manage the pandemic
for eons his advice and
counsel was a big part
of how (indistinct) unscathed and managed
to come out the other side
and finally, it feels kinda normal
that we're having science
on Saturdays once again.
So join me in welcoming Albert.
(audience applauding)
- Well, thank you very much Kurt
for the really very nice introduction
and I really feel privileged
that I'll be the first speaker
after the long pandemic.
And it's certainly important
for all the kids who have
missed out on science on Sunday
during the last two or three years.
So thank you very much for
the kind invitation to speak.
And I'm gonna talk, of course,
about everyone's favorite subject now
that we've left the pandemic.
But just before that, how
many here are scientists?
All right, the kids, how many
want to be scientists? Yeah?
Okay.
All right, let's get into it.
So the topic of today's
lecture is how we use science
to protect people from epidemics.
Kind of an important subject
now that we've come out
of a large pandemic.
And, you know, and so
I'll go through today
about what are kind of
maybe the nuts and bolts
in how we approach these
epidemics or pandemics.
It doesn't turn out to be like this.
You won't unfortunately see
all these cast of actors.
Everybody seen this movie?
- [Audience Member] No.
- [Albert] No? All right.
Okay. Well, you probably
know some of the actors.
Okay so, you know, and
it's actually a good movie.
I liked it.
It actually tells you some
of the nuts and bolts.
You won't be meeting these
people on any of your outbreak
or epidemic or pandemic investigations,
but I would refer you to seeing the movie.
One thing is, is that, you know,
today's subject is really
on science and what we try
to react to or try to address
is, nothing spreads like fear
and the answer to fear is science, okay?
So what I'll go through today
is how I became interested
in science.
I'm an epidemiologist as well
as an infectious disease physician.
And the young kids,
how many know what an epidemiologist does?
All right, good.
It's kind of a funny word,
so I'll go through what an
epidemiologist does in practice
and how we use science to
prevent infectious diseases.
I'll go through what causes kind
of the new infectious threats
that have emerged and are going to emerge.
And then how do we use science to respond
to those new threats?
And I'll just give some
advice at the end, you know,
for young budding
scientists in the audience.
So let me start, and let me
start a story, not my story
but my story of my parents
and their influence.
My mother was a mathematician
and she came to America
to study, her freshman year in Boston,
and there she met my father.
My mother was the person who
actually gave me the love
of science, you know, through mathematics,
through chemistry, putting together
as a high school student,
molecules and so forth.
My father was an engineer.
He didn't really have as much
of an interest in science,
but what he did have
that motivated me was a
disease called tuberculosis.
My parents met in Boston.
My father came, I think in 1953
and very typical immigrant story,
but within two or three months
started coughing up blood.
He was at MIT at that time.
They immediately took him,
put him in what we call a sanitarium.
This was a refuge for where people
with tuberculosis got
treated and he stayed there
for two years.
This is kinda the typical
chest x-ray associated
with tuberculosis.
You can kinda tell that
this side is more wider
than that side.
This side actually has a
cavity that's filled chock full
of the bacteria that causes tuberculosis.
And in those days, you put
people into the hospitals
and these sanitariums
and they stayed there.
My father got daily
injections of new antibiotics
that came out to save the lives
of people with tuberculosis.
Not only my father had
tuberculosis, but my whole family,
my grandmother, my aunts
in Korea had tuberculosis.
And that really highlights,
what I think is a really unique side
of what we do as scientists,
and that's our contributions to society.
And these are 10 of the greatest
public health achievements
that happened not in your lifetime,
but your grandparents' lifetime
and great grandparents' lifetime.
Two of these are really very important
for infectious diseases.
Infectious diseases was the leading killer
of Americans as well as
most people in the world
in the last century.
And these great public health
achievements, all of these,
including ones like family
planning or fluoridation
of drinking water for dental care,
all of these were driven by science.
And just to give you an idea of what you,
as scientists, can do to
contribute to society,
it's really captured in this slide.
It is just a very simplified slide.
Eight hundred thousand
Americans in 1900 died
of an infectious disease each year.
You can see that this sharp
decline in the deaths due
to infectious diseases were
really done to great advances.
Some of them required vaccines,
some of them required antibiotics.
Many of these things required
what we in public health
and epidemiologists do:
clean water, good housing,
secure housing and social rights,
rights to wellbeing,
which created this great,
large decline in deaths.
You can see there's one
spike up here, right?
And we've just underwent a spike like that
with the COVID pandemic.
This was the great
influenza pandemic of 1918
which killed hundreds of
millions of people worldwide
at that time.
But much of these advances
in public health were all due
to science with different teams of people,
different disciplines within
science working together
to make this large societal benefit.
And that benefit didn't only happen here
in the United States, but
happened throughout the world.
This shows, this is my lifetime.
I was born around this time
and within my lifetime,
we've seen dramatic
decreases in little babies,
in little infants dying of
diseases, mostly diarrhea,
malaria, pneumonia, meningitis.
This time, even in the
world's poorest countries,
we've seen sharp declines.
And with that decline in infants dying,
we've had large increases
in life expectancy not only
in the richest countries, but
also in the poorest countries.
Much of this was driven
by infectious diseases,
our advances in infectious
diseases, sanitation, hygiene,
social rights such as good
housing, as well as vaccination.
Many of you who had diarrhea,
you probably maybe took
Pedialyte, this kind of salt,
sugar formula to prevent
the long-term consequences
of diarrhea, on malnutrition.
And so that was kind of my calling.
As Kurt said, I was a chemist
when I was an undergraduate
and one of my professors said that,
"Why don't you do something
that maybe could have potentially,
a broader impact socially?
Why don't you go back to what
your father's story was?"
This was one of my first
mentors, Evan Scrimshaw,
who was one of the champions
of nutrition, good nutrition,
sound nutrition for all back
in the 1960s, 70s and 80s.
And that took me, after I
finished my medical training,
I went to medical school,
did my residency in internal
medicine and then said,
"Okay, where should I go?"
And the place that my mentors
at that time told me to go
to was to go to Brazil
and I actually went to
a city called Salvador.
I hope all of you know in
Brazil, it's in South America,
then America is up here.
This city is in the
Northeast of the country.
It's the oldest city in Brazil.
90% of the population is
African Brazilian descent
because of the intense slave trade.
It's the poorest area
of the country as well.
And this city, like many others in Brazil
but throughout the world,
especially the poorest
countries, look like this.
You can see these high
rises where the rich live
and you can see these
disorganized areas here.
They call these in Portuguese,
(speaks in Portuguese),
islands of inequality that
occur within these cities.
And this type of phenomenon,
the have and the have-nots
exist throughout the world.
And to kinda show you,
this is taking a public health
perspective why that happens,
so the first time in human history,
we have more people in
2007 living in cities
than we did in the countryside.
This is all due to the
massive growth in cities,
the poor people moving
from the countryside
to the cities.
And by 2037, and this is when
you guys will all grow up,
the majority of the world's
population will live in cities
in the poorest areas, poorest
countries of the world.
Okay.
And that change in
urbanization happens together
with changes in what we
call social inequality,
the have and the have-nots,
the rich and the poor.
And you can see this
and one of the reasons
that my mentors told me
to go to Brazil is exactly
captured in this picture.
You can see very clearly that one wall
that separates the have
and the have-nots, okay?
You see on this wall,
you can see everybody has an
apartment with a swimming pool.
They have their tennis courts.
These people go more to
Disney World in Florida
than they ever will jump over
on this other side of the fence,
and that side of the fence
is what we call urban slums
or urban, informal settlements.
Together in the world's population,
the roughly seven, eight billion people,
one billion of the world's population live
in these type of conditions.
In these conditions of
disorganized growth,
people are squatters.
They don't own the land that they live on,
and this picture tells that story.
This picture is from
where we've been working
for the last 25 years in Brazil.
But this picture, you can
take in Lagos, in Africa,
you could take that picture
in Manila, in the Philippines.
You can see this picture in
many places of the world.
You can see this is a community
where half the people live
on less than $2.50 per day.
This is a community that's densely packed,
so people are huddled together,
many times, four or five,
six people in a small, small house.
So you can imagine transmission
of diseases occurring
in these very crowded settings.
You can see that there's
a lack of sanitation,
these open sewers and
there's no refuse collection,
taking out things that
we take for granted here
in New Haven.
And in this environment,
you know, which has happened
due to ecological changes,
50 years ago if you took this picture,
it would be a pristine
Atlantic rain forest.
Now it's a densely crowded
urban, informal settlement.
And here in this type of environment
over what happened over my lifetime,
the most successful
mammalian species, okay,
the most successful mammalian animal here,
is not human beings,
but it's related to all these
little holes that you can see
in this earth and stairwell.
Does anybody know what
those holes are? Yeah.
- [Child] Of like, mouses or rats.
- [Albert] Rats, yeah.
That's where the burrows,
the nests where the
rats make their burrows.
So this is, you can see, very
close to where people live,
all these burrows where rats are.
And this actually leads to
what we call a plague of rats.
This is an article in the science magazine
about the projects we've been
doing in the communities.
You can set out traps here
and capture dozens of rats
in a night.
And there are certain
diseases that we worry about,
and we'll be talking
about this a couple times
'cause this is important for pandemics,
but there are diseases
that are carried by animals
that can spill over and spread to humans,
and in fact cause disease.
One of these is a disease that I never saw
when I was here in the United States,
but I saw a lot the moment I
got off the airplane in Brazil,
is a disease called leptospirosis.
It's caused by a bacteria,
a very thin kinda corkscrew like bacteria.
That corkscrew is important
because that corkscrew,
sorry, the video's not working
but that corkscrew allows the bacteria
to travel very quickly,
kind of like a screw going through water.
And that's important because
these bacteria hang out
in the kidneys of these animals,
many different types of animals,
but one important animal
that carries it is rats
and they shed it out as they
urinate into the environment.
They shed loads of these
bacteria into the environment.
And these bacteria can swim
and when they encounter a human,
they can bore through
the skin or, you know,
let's say the tissues in
your mouth and your eyes.
They can bore through
and then they can spread,
proliferate and cause a massive infection.
And those people who get infected,
they come down with renal failure,
they lose their ability
to their kidney function.
They also come out with massive
bleeding from the lungs,
you know, what we call hemorrhagic fever.
And several days after
I got off the plane,
hospitals were filled with these cases.
And what we saw
when we did our first
outbreak investigation,
sort of like that team in that
first slide for "Contagion,"
we got all these people together,
we started to do an
outbreak investigation.
Back in 1996,
the hospital was filled with
patients with this disease.
Our intensive care unit
where we treat the sickest
people were all getting,
you know, dialysis because
of the kidney failure.
And we had to put them up to
hook them up to a ventilator
because they were bleeding
profusely outta their lungs.
And you can see that every time it rains,
you have these large
epidemics of this disease.
Now I'll talk a little bit
later about why that happens,
but these are outbreaks or epidemics
that happen in these
vulnerable populations,
living in those poor,
urban slums every year,
very predictable outbreaks
that occur same time,
same communities, same people.
So what do we do about that?
And that's why we have epidemiologists,
who are scientists
dedicated for the purpose
of public health to keep people safe.
So epidemiology, and I
think through these talks,
you'll learn a lot about
all the different ologies
and all the different types of sciences,
but epidemiology is the study
of the distribution and causes
of diseases or health related states
in specified populations.
And I think most
importantly, it's the science
of how we control those
health problems that arise.
That's kind of our job to do,
and it's actually a fun job.
You know, many times we're
called into very bad situations.
The COVID pandemic was one.
But many times, the fun part of this is
that we're always doing something new,
always learning something new,
but we're also working with a
lot of different scientists.
We're working with chemists like Kurt.
We're working with
sociologists, economists,
microbiologists, people who
study bacteria and viruses.
We work with a lot of different people,
so we learn a lot and have fun
doing that as well as trying
to do something good like
controlling health problems.
And you can see that many times
if you're an infectious
disease physician like I am,
many times we just think about
the patient and the pathogen
or the virus or the bacteria.
But if you're an epidemiologist,
you have to think about
all of these things.
If you go back to the slides,
you have to think about
how's the environment,
how much people are living on.
Are they able to survive?
Are they being able to
be nourished properly?
Do they have some genetic
factors or biological factors
that may influence them
getting sicker than others?
And also, are there other structures
or other factors like social factors,
the type of leader that you have
that influences how well
people are gonna get treated
or how well we're gonna
prevent the disease?
So this encompasses all of epidemiology,
and that's what makes everything fun.
And the second thing that
we did was not only what
to study, but how we're gonna study it.
So this is a program
that we started a year
after I stepped off the plane.
We already done several outbreak
investigations and we said,
"Hey, you know,
what we need to do is to
train more scientists,"
scientists like you in the audience
and we had to train them
in many different things.
So we started this back in 1996.
One of the most important parts is
that the best ways to prevent disease is
to do this through the community,
not sitting in a university or not sitting
in a research institute,
but actually working in the community.
And so one of our foundational
principles was community
as equal partners.
And what we did is similar to what Kurt
and everyone is doing here,
is that we had high school,
headstart programs,
college work study programs
in the communities that were
affected by these diseases
so we could train scientists
who can solve their own
problems, where they live,
rather than have somebody outside come in.
And so these are actually
our high school students.
You can see that, you know,
we teach 'em how to use a computer
but one of the key things in the computer
that you can do is you can analyze data.
You can analyze large amounts of data,
and we can get that
data in kinda cool ways.
One of the things that we
do is give the students,
we have them go out and
we give them GPS devices,
almost like Google does
when they go by your house.
We give them these cameras
and they can just take
pictures along the way.
We also give them drones.
The kids like that, you
know, kids like that a lot.
And so these kids are
going out, using drones
to find out all the places
that may be potentially
transmitting the diseases
that we're working on.
Here, you can see some students
here that are going around
and surveying all the places
where diseases like leptospirosis,
that rat borne disease, could occur.
And we use this to address
a whole bunch of problems.
One of the big killers when
I came down was meningitis,
a disease that we hardly see
here in the United States,
but a disease that we could
prevent with vaccines,
or diseases that are
transmitted by mosquitoes.
But let's go back to leptospirosis.
So this is a disease where
you have to have the rat
because the rat's the animal
which kinda sheds the bacteria
that infects people.
And this is a very typical scene.
This is the backyard of
almost everybody who lives
in the study site where
we've been working,
where I showed those photos
and you can see that they're
chock full of rats, okay?
Rats, I don't know if anyone
here has captured rats.
I did it for about five years and gave up
and let the students do it,
but not easy to capture rats.
You have to go out in
the middle of the night.
Sometimes it's not safe.
Sometimes they don't like
the bait you give them.
We give them Gorgonzola cheese and bacon,
you know, and so it becomes
a little bit expensive
to capture rats.
So we had a really smart Yale
graduate student, PhD student,
Kate Hacker that said,
"Hey, maybe there's a
better way to do this."
And this is actually science in action.
And she said, "Okay, what's a cheap way
that we could do is," so
she took ceramic tiles,
each ones cost about 50 cents,
and she painted them with ink.
And then she laid them out like here
and throughout the community,
and then she started counting
how many paw prints are rats
or sometimes rats like to
scratch at these tiles,
so looking at the tail marks
or the scratch marks of these.
And using that and by counting
how many are in a tile,
she came up with a way to make a map,
a map of what we call rattiness,
places that are more
rattier than others, okay?
And why is that important?
So remember what an epidemiologist does.
We're not there just to kinda say,
"Okay, this is where rats live
and this is where not rats live."
But we wanna use these
maps and in the past,
we used to have to draw all this
but now we have computers that
can really make nice images.
But we wanna draw these maps
to tell us where do we need
to go to do prevention.
Where do we need to know to control rats?
If we can't do it everywhere,
what are the places that
we need to go first, okay?
And that's what this rat tells us.
This tells us a big problem
that I can be standing here
and there'll be a lot of rats,
but if I go 20 meters or 20 yards there,
the concentration of rats
are very different, okay?
And so we have to have not only
people who know where to go,
we also have to have teams that know how
to control these rats.
We either give them
pesticides or we do education
and we use our youth groups to
actually teach the residents,
many times the adults in the community how
to control their rat populations
through sequestering food,
not allowing refuse to be stored,
securing water sources
so the rats can't drink
or putting safe water
supplies in these communities.
The other facet is that
if the rat is urinating the
bacteria in the environment,
what happens if it rains?
And these pictures here
tell an important story
in the daily lives of these
residents of urban slums.
So this is a very typical scene
where every time it rains,
the residents have to
go into the open sewer,
dig it out so that they
can create a barrier.
So the next time it rains,
it doesn't overflow into their households.
This is a resident showing
how high the flooding goes
and how high the flooding goes.
And so in these events,
you can see many times they're
going bare feet, right,
without any protection.
So these residents get
exposed to an environment,
the sewage water or the dirt
which is contaminated by the bacteria,
and then the bacteria can
penetrate into the skin
and cause an infection,
and that's why we have
these large outbreaks.
So again, we like making maps
so that we know who's at most at risk
and where do we need to go.
And when we made these maps,
and these was actually with
a geographer and an engineer,
you know, team coming in,
helping us to make these maps,
the people with the highest
risk, yeah go ahead.
- [Audience Member 2] So like,
you know how the water gets contaminated?
Wouldn't the plants also be affected?
So if you eat a plant that
absorbs the (indistinct)?
- [Albert] Yeah.
Yeah, that's a good question
and that also is a way
that people get infected.
So you could be working there,
you know, and your skin is
exposed, but also if your plants
or many times people will
store food like, you know,
soda or packages, when it floods,
that all will get contaminated
and when they eat it,
the bacteria can enter into the mouth,
what we call the oral cavity
and cause an infection.
So that's an important thing.
So you can imagine in this
setting where it rains
and it gets flooded,
everything gets contaminated.
And the people who have most
risk are those people who,
not only live by an open sewer,
but those people who are at
the bottom of the valley.
So just to remind you,
this is an overly poor,
you know, community.
Half of these people
live like $2.50 in a day,
but you can appreciate that
even within those valleys,
there are people who are
more vulnerable than others.
You can see that these houses
have much better structure
than the ones at the bottom of the valley
that get continually flooded.
Many times in the ones at the bottom,
they have to continually raise their house
because all the silt,
all the sediment and dirt
from the top of their valley floods,
what do you call it, goes down
to the bottom of the valley.
In this situation, you know,
and many of you come from many,
you know, not only here in New Haven,
but many different parts of the world,
you'll see this situation
where the most vulnerable,
those at most risk for disease
are the people who are living
in the worst houses, who
are living by sewers,
who are living in places that get flooded,
whether it's in Mumbai in India,
or whether it's in Guayaquil in Ecuador,
whether it's in Jakarta in Indonesia,
any place in the world.
And by doing this study, and again,
this was driven by people like you,
young students going out there mapping,
taking a map where now
we have them on tablets,
we give them tablets and drawing out
where all those open sewers are.
And what we are able to
do is to do interventions,
going back to what the
principle of epidemiology,
our goal is to control disease.
And so we had some of our
students develop rapid tests,
much like what you use for COVID, okay?
They identified pieces of the
bacteria that could be used
to detect the people get infected so
that every time it rains,
we can alert the physician
and give them antibiotics to prevent them
from getting that massive
bleeding in their lungs
or their renal failure.
We also did rat control.
We would send out teams
working with the government
to go target those areas
where the highest rat populations are,
but also the highest risk
for getting this disease leptospirosis.
Probably the most important
thing that we did was to work
together with the community and actually
in a community participatory model,
much like what brings you here today
where we're working with leaders,
we're working with the community.
And by working together,
and at this time of my life,
I was working with the
Brazilian Ministry of Health,
we're able to convince the
ministry of finance to give money
to close the sewers in all those regions
of the city where they had
open sewers and high risk
of getting this life-threatening disease.
And by doing all of this,
we were able, within 10 years, to get
about a fivefold reduction.
We decreased the number
of cases of leptospirosis
that would come into our
hospitals every year by 90%,
no 80 to 90%.
So this is a good example of
not only science in action,
but also an example
of how young people can make
a difference through science.
And the third thing is that
how people from different types
of sciences can work all
together for something
that could provide a societal benefit.
So yeah, please.
- [Audience Member 3]
In the previous slide,
is he doing dissections?
- [Albert] Yeah, so this is one
of our students who actually
captured these rats,
is dissecting the rat, right,
you know, to find out what's in it.
And the reason why they're
in this hazmat suit is
because these rats are not only,
I just talked about this
one bacteria, leptospirosis,
but they are also carriers of a virus,
which is very easily transmittable.
It's called hantovirus.
So every time, you can imagine Salvador
where we work, the city in
Brazil, it's a tropical climate.
It's probably 90 degrees, 80% humidity.
So they're spending the whole day
in these suits doing science, right?
So, an extraordinary team
of Brazilians and Americans
and French and English
who have worked together
to do this study.
Did I answer your question?
- [Audience Member 3]
Yeah, so they're dissecting
to understand what's...
- [Albert] What's in those rats, yeah,
for leptospirosis and off and on, yeah.
All right, good. So that's a good example.
So I wanted to start
out with leptospirosis
because it kinda sets us
up for a specific theme.
And this is a challenge for
not my generation anymore,
but your generation, all the young ones.
We are going to have, a question?
(child speaking indistinctly)
- [Albert] I'm sorry, say it again?
- [Parent] He's good. Our
house here in New Haven floods.
- [Albert] Floods, okay.
Yeah, so okay, yeah.
So my house floods also in New Haven.
And how many people have seen rats here?
Okay, where do you see them?
- [Audience Member 4] In basements.
- In basements, okay.
Where else do you see them?
(child speaking indistinctly)
Okay, yeah.
Especially if you have food
in those basements. Yeah.
(child speaking indistinctly)
Yeah. I'm sorry?
- [Child 2] Sometimes in the attics.
- Sometimes in the attics.
Sometimes, so there are
rats which are bigger ones
and there are also mice
which are smaller ones.
Many times you'll see the mice,
you can see rats in the attic as well
but many times, they're mice, okay?
Has anybody here been to New York City?
- [Audience Member] Yes.
- All right, anybody been to
a subway in New York City?
- [Audience Member 5] Yes.
- All right.
Anybody seen a rat in the
subway in New York City?
Okay. (laughs)
All right.
New York City, the subways
are filled with rats.
So why doesn't somebody
in New York City get this
life-threatening disease,
it does happen,
but somebody in Brazil living
in that community does?
(audience member speaking indistinctly)
Yeah.
So New York City has
closed, exactly spot on,
New York City has closed sewers.
So when the contaminated water
with this bacteria doesn't
flow into our bedrooms,
doesn't flow into our play space,
it stays in those sewers.
The second thing is that, that distance,
remember that slide that I showed
with all those rat burrows?
Those are right next to
where people live, okay?
They have no option but to every day,
walk through that area
whereas in New York,
if you see 'em in the sewer,
they're not right by where we are, right?
And usually we're not barefoot, right?
So we have several barriers
that protect us, okay?
This is why this is a
disease of the poor, okay?
It's a disease that we see
in tropical climates, okay,
and it's a disease that we rarely see
unless you're traveling to Hawaii.
They have leptospirosis in Hawaii,
so anyone seen all the
warning signs there,
but very few situations where people here,
people like you and I are going
to encounter leptospirosis.
But this also kind of
highlights some key themes
about challenges that your, yeah please.
(audience member speaking indistinctly)
Rabies, so rats don't carry rabies.
They carry other diseases
that we worry about.
This is one of them, right?
But they can also carry other diseases.
Rabies, we're worried a
little bit more about dogs,
bats, raccoons, other types of animals,
sometimes rabbits, okay?
Yep, please.
(child speaking indistinctly)
I'm sorry?
So rats don't have
rabies. They can't carry.
So some animals can carry a
disease and not carry others.
And that's the question
for a scientist, right?
You have to do science.
Sometimes we don't really know,
why certain animals carry some disease
and others don't carry another.
And that's gonna be important,
so I'll come back to your
question in a second, okay?
And that's important when
we think about these type
of emerging infectious diseases,
but let me go through some of these.
So the big challenges
for my generation was how
to improve the health of
all, not just the rich
but also the poor.
Challenge for your generation,
at least for infectious diseases,
it's gonna be the bigger problems
and those problems that
are gonna be caused
by rapid urbanization,
like I showed in all the
communities that we talked to,
all those disorganized communities
that are rapidly expanding.
The other's climate change.
You can imagine how, yep, go ahead.
- [Child 3] Also, COVID actually
started because of that.
- [Albert] Yeah, exactly.
Wow this group, Kurt,
I don't think I have to give this talk.
I think they know everything.
All right, good, good.
Yeah, so let me give a good example.
Climate change is gonna be important.
So remember those people
digging out their sewers?
Well, those people,
if it rains more and it
rains more violently,
they're gonna have to be exposed more
and more to this disease, okay?
So climate change with these
extreme weather events,
hurricanes, typhoons, cyclones, monsoons,
this is something that's
going to be a challenge
for all of you in the next decades.
The other is the changing
land use and ecosystems.
You saw the precarious
way these communities,
one billion of our
world's population live.
And I think it sounds like everyone knows
that we can get new
infections from animals, okay?
And there's several good examples of that.
We'll go through it. COVID is one.
And then the other is
that once we're infected
with a new infection, we
can spread it quickly.
Why? Because we move much more.
I think when I was growing up,
for the first 15 years of my life,
I didn't step outside of the
state of New Jersey, okay?
Now, my children have been
all over the world, right,
like many of you will, okay?
So we're moving a lot more
than we did in the past.
And the other is that our population,
not just here in the United States,
but many places in the
world is getting older
and older people many
times are more susceptible
or have more risk of
getting severe infections.
So all of these things
are gonna be challenges
that you're gonna have to deal with,
you know, in the future.
And let's get back to the
question before about why animals,
so you know, some of these
animals carry rabies.
Bats can cause rabies.
Camels have been reported,
but very infrequently
to cause rabies.
But there are certain diseases
that we really worry about
that occur in animals
that may spread to humans.
The big one is influenza.
There's a current thought
that the 1918 pandemic
that happened was actually
due to across a spillover
or spread of a bird influenza to humans.
So that's one of the
things that we worry about.
As we all know, SARS-CoV-1
is another one, okay?
The first SARS virus,
this is back in 2003,
this was due to spread from a civet
that was in a marketplace
and went to a restaurant.
Actually my friend did this investigation
in the people's Republic of
China and found the restaurant
that actually caused
that spread to humans.
And there's another virus called MERS,
which is a cousin of the COVID virus
which is carried by camels.
And bats can do many of these.
So you can see that
there are certain animals
that can cause infection,
but also certain practices
and certain behaviors
that place us at risk.
So for example, Ebola, it's bushmeat.
For SARS-CoV-1,
it's many times these
what we call wet markets,
so these markets where
you bring wildlife animal
that are used for consumption,
or bird influenza.
We have huge farms in the United States
where we produce a lot of
chicken that get infected
with bird influenza.
These are all potential causes.
And I think just for the time,
I'm gonna skip this part and let's end up
with a good example, okay?
And all of you have passed through this
and you may pass through
this again in the future,
but we are leaving the pandemic
but I think it's good to reflect for you
about why science is so
important and what it has done
for us in the last three years.
So, we really don't know
exactly how the virus spread
from animals to humans, okay?
There's still quite a bit of debate,
but we know that that first
initial outbreak happened
in China, caused a large outbreak.
And what's implicated were
these markets where many times,
you'll put one animal with
one species on top of another
and then they're all
breathing or urinating,
defecating on top of each other
and they're spreading, spreading viruses.
So that's where that
initial event happened.
But going back to kinda those drivers
and why we really worry about
pandemics is this situation,
these are all the airplane flights
between all the cities in the world.
So you could take that
map of airplane flights
and just put that on top of what we saw.
This is based on using
molecular biology or genomics,
what we saw about the spread
of the SARS-CoV-2 virus
or the COVID virus in the
first three or four months
of the pandemic, right?
It's interesting that one
of the only nonstop flights
from Wuhan, which started,
went exactly to Milan
because of the fashion industry, you know?
Wuhan produces a lot of the clothes
that Italian fashion makers use,
and there's a direct
flight and Italy was one
of the first and hardest hit countries
that was affected by the COVID pandemic.
So this is a good example
of how the world is moving
and how we're at increased
risk for once a virus happens,
that it spreads quickly.
And these are some of the challenges
that we faced during the pandemic,
well first that this was a new virus
that was never experienced by any of us,
not only in this room but in the world,
you know, prior to the pandemic.
And that virus, because
we never experienced it,
none of us had immunity.
We're all susceptible to that virus.
The second is, is that this
was a virus because it was new,
we didn't understand its biology.
This is the importance of science.
Without understanding its biology,
we can't make diagnostic tests,
we can't make therapies or treatments
to treat people who got sick.
We can't prevent it with
making vaccines and so forth.
So, that was a key challenge.
The next was that this was
a highly transmissible virus
'cause many of you, probably more than 50%
of you have gotten COVID in this room,
whether you knew it or not.
But this is a virus that
could be transmitted
before you got sick, which is
important because if I'm sick,
I'll stay in my room
but if I don't know if I can
transmit it before I get sick,
maybe I don't know and
I'm going to classes
and meeting people.
And the other was what
we call super spreading,
you know, where one person may spread it
to more people than another person,
which makes it very difficult to identify,
who is the person who's
actually causing transmission
in the community.
The other problem, as we, you know,
sorely learned in the
beginning of the pandemic is
that this was a more virulent virus,
more virulent than influenza,
okay, with the people.
And then the further challenges,
as we progressed through the pandemic,
one was mutations, okay?
Does everybody, have you
heard about mutations?
All right, good, good.
So this virus, like all of us,
we have mutations that are
happening in our bodies
but this virus had mutations
whose strains were selected
for, which created more transmissible,
even more highly transmissible variants,
innervated the immune response.
Some of you may have heard
of the Omicron variant.
That's a good example.
So this pandemic,
the pandemic we started
with is not the pandemic
that we ended with.
And then I think the last one,
which was really important is
that we did a lot of good science.
We did a lot of catch up,
especially our biologists,
our immunologists, you know, the chemists.
Yep.
(Speaker speaking indistinctly)
Or we can spread to animals.
So this is a good example.
Boy, that's a very good question.
You guys are thinking
about contagion a lot.
So we can get infections from animals,
but we can also pass those
infections back to animals.
So a lot of good examples
of dogs getting COVID,
cats getting COVID, tigers
in zoos getting COVID,
giraffes getting COVID and dying of COVID
that they didn't get from another animal.
They got it from the zookeeper,
or they got it from the
pet owner that got COVID,
and that makes it very
difficult to control, right?
If it's only humans, well,
there are things we can do
with humans like vaccinate.
But if it's animals that
are infected as well,
those type of diseases
are very difficult to,
you know, certainly
eliminate or eradicate,
but also to control in the short term.
So the other problem
is, is that we did a lot
of good science in biology
and in the chemistry
and in the, what do you call it,
in the immunology of the disease
and the genetics of the disease.
But we didn't really do
a lot of good scientists
and we didn't have a lot of
trained scientists working
on those type of behavioral interventions,
those things that we can do
to make people get vaccinated more
or make people wear face masks
or promote social distancing, there.
So we need more scientists
specifically in this area
that can some give good advice to leaders
and have the leaders
make the right decisions.
And this is just the aftermath, right?
We're kind of in the
aftermath of the pandemic.
We've had just the United States alone,
over 1.1 million people who
died during this epidemic.
So large, devastating
cost, happened over waves.
Many of our population
have gotten infected.
Many of our population have
also gotten vaccinated.
And there are really
good, what do you call it,
key scientific achievements
and this is really how science
can make for a better society
and a healthier society.
We had molecular tests and rapid tests.
We were able to test the sewage water
to understand how much transmission
comes in the community.
We learned early on that social distancing
and wearing face masks,
those kind of barrier types of
interventions were effective.
Within the first six
months of the pandemic,
we learned that certain
drugs like steroids followed
by monoclonal antibodies
and antiviral agents were effective.
And then I think probably the
most important one was safe
and effective vaccines,
such as maybe the vaccines
that many of you in this room have taken,
these mRNA vaccines.
So those were really great
breakthroughs that kept,
you know, what could have
been an even more devastating,
pandemic, less so.
And just to tell you that, you know,
there are a lot of people
who worked on this at Yale,
really heroic efforts.
This is, one group had
the privilege to lead.
It was called the Yale
Impact team, you know,
which mounted a response the first week.
This is March 2nd of 2020, even
before we had the first case
and doing things like using saliva,
your spit to detect whether
you're infected or not, okay?
The other was that wastewater
surveillance setting up
in New Haven, understanding
whether we had transmission
or not by testing the sewage water.
And one of the things that
we had to do was protect,
like in Brazil, those photos,
the people who are most
vulnerable in our population.
And who were they?
They were, first of all,
the people living in the
cities, Hartford, Waterbury,
New Haven, Bridgeport, Stanford.
Those cities, which were
also the most vulnerable,
had the highest what we call
social vulnerability index.
These were the cities that got hit hardest
in our communities during
that terrible first wave.
The other population
was their nursing homes.
11% of all our nursing
home residents, you know,
died during that first one
month of that pandemic.
And that's when, you know,
this is I think the other part
which is that there's one
thing that we do day-to-day
whether it's in the
laboratory or in the field,
or in the community, to do
science and to get evidence,
but the other key part is
to work with the leaders
in making, translating that
evidence and that science
and putting it into action.
And, you know,
I had the privilege of being
called on, as Kurt said,
by Governor Lamont to
co-chair with Indra Nooyi,
who was the former CEO of PepsiCo
so somebody who wasn't a scientist,
but was important to get a balance so
that we could think of how we
could first protect the state
and then how we could reopen it
'cause many of people had
lost their employment,
people they needed who were
working in the restaurants,
who are working as taxi
drivers and so forth,
lost their jobs during that period.
So how could we safely reopen the state?
And I think the major guiding principle,
and this is I think really as hopefully,
you know, as a justification
why science is important is
that you need science in
order to do everything else,
to reopen the economy, to
keep people, hospitals safe,
to keep people protected, to
minimize harm that may occur.
If we were too rigorous in
keeping everybody at home,
you know, safe at home, people
would be losing their jobs.
People would be losing their income.
They wouldn't have money
to feed their children.
So one of the two things,
just wanted to highlight
of that plan was, we were
called in on April 13th
which was the peak of the pandemic,
first wave in Connecticut.
As I mentioned,
11% by then of our nursing
home residents had died.
And one of the most important things is
that we didn't have enough tests.
We were doing 200 tests per week.
We were having all of our
laboratories in the state,
Jackson Labs, Yale, Hartford Healthcare,
all of them were developing new tests
but we had to get them to the people
because the hospitals wouldn't
allow anybody to come in
unless you were diagnosed with COVID.
So we went within two months
from about 200 kits per day
to about 20,000 kits today by
using all the laboratories,
all the scientists, just
calling them all up.
It was sort of like
World War II, you know,
calling everybody up who could do a test
and getting them on board.
The second thing that we
did was to vaccinate people.
Once the vaccines were approved
on December 22nd, 2020,
rolled them out.
Many of you may have remembered,
we had these large testing centers as well
as large vaccination centers.
You'd go into your car,
roll up your sleeve, open the
window and you get vaccinated.
So all of that was driven by science,
driven by best practices
that we had at that time
and you could see that
horrible first epidemic
and then how that decreased, you know,
through time pretty much
because of vaccination
and access to healthcare.
And Kurt, I'm going over a little bit.
Is that okay, just two more minutes?
Yeah, so I think the
most important thing is
that who you are, and this goes back
to the foundational
principles of epidemiology,
our goal is to control disease
and protect the population.
And the populations that suffered most
during that initial phase
of the epidemic were the
nursing home population,
but also our African-American
and Latino populations.
African-Americans and
Latinos died five times more
than our white population in our state
during that first wave.
And the only answer to
that was science, okay,
getting testing and vaccination
to those populations.
And you can see by the end,
by our third pandemic wave,
we had no difference between mortality
between our African American population
and white population.
And still an elevated population,
increased risk of dying
among our Latino population.
So more work needs to be done,
but large drops in mortality that occurred
because of the public health
action driven by science.
So let me end up with just two slides
and again, thank you Kurt,
It's really an honor and
a privilege to be talking,
especially this is the first
talk after the pandemic.
But let me go back a
little bit and just think
about what helped me when
I was in your position.
I had really great mentors.
My high school chemistry
teacher was the one, my mother
and my high school chemistry
teacher were probably,
the two most important people in my lives
in teaching me about
science and motivating me
and enjoying science, right,
and enjoying to talk about science.
I think the other people in my
lives were kind of the people
during my college, you know, professors
in medical school where they said,
"Why don't you do this?
You know, pick an
important question, okay?
And then go for it."
And for all of you in this room,
particularly the young generation,
these are the important questions, right?
How do we reduce inequalities?
How do we reduce poverty?
How do we do we mitigate hunger?
How do we address climate change?
How do we do affordable and clean energy?
Those are the key issues.
This is not just for our public health,
but this involves physics,
astronomy, it involves, you know,
sociology, anthropology, all
of the different sciences.
The second is, is that
learn constantly and put
in practice the new things you learn.
I'm still learning today and importantly,
I'm learning from people
much younger than me.
I was just in Brazil a month ago.
I'm learning from the 14 and 15 year olds.
They're telling me new things
about something I thought
I knew something about,
every time I meet them.
I think the other thing that
we don't really emphasize
as much, but it's to
talk about science, okay?
It's fun to talk about science,
but also to be an advocate for science.
You are the future leaders
and we will need more
and more scientists like you
to advise leaders, such as
the governor or the president
and so forth about what's the best way
to move forward, okay?
So your role in society is enormous.
So with that, let me end.
Apologies Kurt for going over,
but just to say thank you
to everyone, and welcome.
(audience applauding)
(mellow jingle)